how strong our favorite electricity
powered characters from TV and film look
great footage of them like it's real
video evidence make physicists study
them to extract hard numbers on how
shocking they are then make them compete
in a challenge of our own design to
crown one the most powerful this is
power levels today's competitors are two
of the most popular electrical
characters Pikachu from the Pokemon
series an electro specifically Jamie
Foxx from the amazing spider-man 2 what
that's what he looks like in the movie
fraud challenges they'll have to absorb
the most lightning bolts explode the
most toads in a single glass and power a
major American city the longest ever
performs the best in each challenge gets
a point and the most points after all
three is crowned our most powerful let's
go we begin with each competitor getting
hit by lightning so first we have to
find out how much electricity each one
can store in their body
Electro's most impressive feat of
suckage is when he absorbs all the
electricity in the area around Times
Square the company con Edison estimates
that the average power consumption of
the entire district is 161 megawatts and
in the film he absorbs all of that
energy in nine point zero five seconds
energy is power multiplied by time which
means electro is able to safely absorb 1
billion four hundred and fifty seven
million joules or about the same amount
of energy as getting hit by a 757 going
345 miles per hour for Pikachu will have
to back our way into how much energy he
can absorb by assuming it's the same as
the max amount of energy he can shoot
out this will be a bit more complicated
let's analyze his strongest onscreen
blast a special z crystal charged
Thunderbolt attack from Pokemon Sun and
Moon if you're unfamiliar using a Z
crystal and a pokemon is like giving
your dog meth before a dog fight and yes
Pokemon is messed up enough to deserve
that metaphor we'll need to pull three
things from this attack to determine
pikas max energy the distance it travels
the resistance of the air it moves
through and its voltage the voltage is
the easiest to find because ash just
shouts it out before he attacks
never change Japan for the attacks
distance will take the average height of
a ten-year-old girl as Lily is in the
scene that measure everything in terms
of Lily's using Lily's we can mark out a
cylinder of air and treat it like a
piece of wire the current has to pass
through this allows us to determine the
resistance air actually has a pretty
high resistance to the flow of
electrical charge but with a big enough
voltage the particles get ripped apart
and create a super bright plasma fun
fact this plasma is the reason lightning
is light with all that calculated we can
arrive at our answer for Pikachu's max
electrical power 150 1.61 megawatts or
enough to power the average home for
more than 13 years and since his attack
was active for ten point nine two
seconds we can calculate that he was
able to expend one point six six billion
joules of energy at max effort we'll
take this to be his maximum energy
storage capacity now take a look at
their energy storage side-by-side with
the average energy of a single lightning
bolt they could both take one blast but
the second one would fry both of their
circuitry this isn't so much to point
out how weak our characters are as it is
to say lightning you scary so to help us
tip the scales we'll consider that
Pikachu can only handle this much energy
with a special Z crystal boosting his
ability while electro can always
maintain his literal power levels giving
him the point for challenge one and now
on to challenge two where we answer the
age-old question what happens to a toad
when it's struck by lightning don't play
the clip don't do it you know what
happens to a toad
struck by lightning same thing that
happens to everything
Oh No now let's see how many toads each
character could blow up at once they'll
do this by discharging all of their
stored energy to instantaneously boil
the water inside as many toads as
possible causing their rapid expansion
into a gaseous state and subsequent
explosion the average mass of a common
toad is 0.8 ounces 0.6 of which is
likely water and since they're
cold-blooded will assume that water is
room temperature with this info we can
find out how much energy it would take
to blow up one toad 44,000 joules or to
put it in terms everyone can understand
the energy it takes to heat three hot
pockets in an eleven hundred watt
microwave
Pikachu's max energy discharge is
slightly larger than Electra's max
energy storage so he'll have the edge in
this challenge but how many toes would
he take the lead by if we divide both of
their total energy capacities by the
energy required to zap a single frog
electro could explode thirty three
thousand thirty eight unlucky amphibians
let's Pikachu could take out thirty
seven thousand six hundred forty one lil
slippies take that end of Magnolia and
Pikachu wins the point for challenge
number two now on to challenge three who
can power the grid of a major American
city the longest if we divide each
competitors total energy by the total
power consumption of San Francisco well
find that electro could power San Fran
for five point three eight seconds while
Pikachu could hold on a little longer
for six point one three
giving him the point in this challenge
and the overall competition
Congrats Pikachu science has declared
you the more powerful electrical
character Oh little monster
I could rain on your parade by pointing
out how even your strongest attack is
still far too weak to create actual
real-world lightning but if I rained on
your parade we'd probably get
electrocuted were you shocked at the
result well too bad
the data doesn't care about your
favorites but we care about you let us
know who you want to see compete in the
future episodes and you might see them
out right here and the neck
episode of power levels
[Music]